[Music]
congratulations to mp8 for being the
winner of our speaker giveaway please
email me and we'll get you your prize
for those of you who have been asking
yes we will be doing another speaker
system giveaway and we will be doing it
very very soon so stay tuned I posted a
video a few days ago about some details
on Avengers 4 that the spider-man
homecoming to plot league gave us many
of you asked me for the actual plot
leaked for spider-man homecoming 2 so
that is what this video is about again I
know that this leak is in no way
confirmed but this came from the same
person who posted about Avengers
infinity war who ended up being right
about everything that he posted so there
is some credibility to it if you do not
want any possible potential spoilers for
spider-man homecoming 2 now is the time
to turn away so to start off the source
says that the plot is in fact set after
vendors for Peters revived and Anna
Pierce Tony Stark will indeed die and
Peter will be mourning his death the
plot will revolve around something
groundbreaking that Stark has created
and then it's stolen and spider-man must
retrieve it Mysterio is said to be the
main villain in this sequel Mysterio is
a master of illusion and he's a thief
and he's the one that has apparently
stolen Starks creation if you have been
following news around spider-man
homecoming 2 you'll know that Jake
Gyllenhaal is said to play Mysterio but
it has not yet been confirmed and
apparently Mysterio actually stole this
for a mysterious employer that hired him
more on that in a bit the sequel is set
to mainly take place in London Peter and
his friends are there for a conference
that is sponsored by stark industry and
also Pepper Potts is said to be in the
movie as well which would make perfect
sense because Tony and Peter were really
really close Tony felt responsible for
Peter and if Tony's gone it would make
sense that Pepper would somewhat feel
responsible and close and connected to
Peter as well characters that are said
to return our MJ Ned Liz flash and Aunt
May along with the Midtown students and
staff from homecoming they are
introducing a new character who is at
mi6 operative and she's pursuing
Mysterio
she begrudgingly teams up with
spider-man to stop him and her name is
Jessica drew for those of you who do not
know who Jessica drew is in the comics
she is Spider Woman but don't get
excited just yet because according to
the sleek she has no superpowers but she
is an expert in combat and skilled
tactician I really hope this isn't true
because I would really like Spider Woman
to be introduced to the MCU however if
she doesn't have these powers in
homecoming - it's not that hard to give
her these powers in another movie so I
really hope they're just introducing her
here and eventually they will set it up
to where she becomes Spider Woman it
wouldn't be the first time that in the
MCU the origin story of a character has
been changed they are introducing two
more new characters and they may sound
familiar to you Alistair Smythe and
Spencer Smythe
according to this leaked peter develops
a rivalry with Alistair Smythe Alistair
Smythe being a technology prodigy is
determined to upstage Peter and
allister's father Spencer Smythe is
apparently working for Stark Industries
just some quick info on these two
characters Spencer Smythe is known for
creating the spider-slayers
who are a series of robots that sought
to destroy spider-man and his son
Alistair later becomes the villain known
as the ultimate Spider Slayer the leak
indicates that vulture and scorpion will
both appear in the sequel but will only
play minor roles scorpion is apparently
working for the same man who hired
Mysterio to steal Starks creation and
they attempt to get vulture to betray
spider-man's identity to them and
apparently yes they are building up the
sinister six in this movie although they
may not all appear perhaps in the third
spider-man Home Coming movie we will see
Spidey take on the sinister six so as
far as this mysterious employer that
hires Mysterio to steal Starks creation
it is said that it is going to be a
major villain from the comics it has
also said that this villain is going to
be prominent in the spider-man movies
going forward we're not sure who this
villain is yet and they said that this
villain will only have a minor role in
the next spider-man movie but Sony and
Marvel are eyeing a list actors to play
the part there are many many villains
that this could be however it is widely
believed that is going to be one of two
either
Norman Osborn or
Green Goblin or ting pit I would
probably guess that they would do
Osborn over kingpin but that's just my
personal opinion or if they're going to
set up the sinister six in future movies
maybe even Doctor Octopus or they can
just do us all a favor and throw
spider-man in the new venom movie coming
out and then venom in the next
spider-man movie well that's it for the
plot leaked the only thing left is to
say that apparently as of right now the
title is spider-man field trip what do
you all think about this plot for the
next spider-man sequel let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and let
me know who you think will be the
mysterious villain if you enjoyed this
video click that thumbs up button please
and don't forget to subscribe to my
channel to stay up-to-date on spider-man
homecoming - marvel and all things
superhero thank you so much for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]